I am going to be in Detroit October 21st
get your tickets at the Jack White
theater chrisley.com
I guess
that week or something is usually
reserved for some thing some Festival
okay
so I booked this show in Detroit
Michigan
I don't know three months ago two days
ago I get an onslaught of messages [__]
you dude you're destroying jobs in
Detroit
your hundreds of people are are are
begging on this you're ruining hundreds
of thousands of dollars
in in our Detroit economy because of
[__] you
and I see all these comments and I go
huh
the lovely comedian goes huh hey you're
taking our date that we have every year
our economy thrives
and I go huh they say you're ruining it
and I go huh I do a little bit of
research still can't figure out what's
going on people are just slaughtering me
in my comments you piece of [__] cancel
the date now they're saying
I got comments DMs
crystallia cancel the date now and I now
you know what it is now you oh you know
what it is you know what it is when
people come at me like that I go like
this no
I don't even know what's going on by the
way see here's the here's the toxicity
of our city of our city dude you gotta
have a dialogue come at me regular hey
did you know that there is a festival
that's now not gonna happen because and
by the way dude it's not gonna happen
because of me
if it's sold well and if it was the [__]
like you say it is it would still be
there you know why you know why I do it
capitalism that's why
I'ma sell this [__] out I don't know
what I don't even know what the [__]
thing is every year I don't know what it
is the theater goes like this yeah
crystalia come perform
I say okay
and now three months later oh they're
not having the I can't hold my mask up
like this
and throw a [__] bean bag out at a
Target and make a guy with you know
puffy pants fall in a in a [__] dunk
tank all right dude don't come at me
like that
don't come at me like that I don't give
a [__] now whoops
ah
I done now don't give a [__]
how do you sit I want you to understand
something if these people sincerely
asked me and said man I'm really
heartbroken this sucks like you know
usually we do this and that I would have
actually investigated it I would have
actually asked my people about hey what
is this I don't want to ruin this [__]
but now
oh God I'll be there
it's not how it works dude don't push me
that's what I say so now can't wait to
perform in Detroit can't wait to roast
you [__] [__] when I'm there
I'm coming out like this with one of
these
and big pants with the [__] shitty
argyle socks
hello welcome to the Chrisley show
grab your seats settle in for a dark
tail and I'm just gonna [__] talk
about like [__] myself and cell
phones like my whatever my ACT is you
know
that's a disrespect dude
that's kind of [__] cancel your show now
by the way everyone who wrote me it was
like a cartoon Avatar
it's just so [__] like go [__]
yourself dude I don't know about this I
don't know about this it's not my fault
and me and another comedian was another
night I don't even know the guy but it
was like it was like you and you cancel
the show and I go like this [__] hell
no dude I'm gonna start a tour with that
other comedian and I'm just gonna run
every every year same year it's going to
be the crystalia festival now in Detroit
so thank you very much nice to meet you
crazy crazy
[Music]